free tickets just on thousands and
thousands of free tickets just gone with
the wind I just haven't had time to sit
back and really like sob about this like
as you can see that's Jesus Christ we
all know by now Tana Khan was a disaster
it was a failed
[Applause]
but we haven't really been told why why
did it fail
why did Tennant Khan go so bad how did
he get so out of control well the
message that we were told initially was
that 15,000 people just showed up they
just showed up magically that's right oh
[Music]
my gosh 20,000 people it started off
with 20 and it started off for something
really cool like guys you won't believe
this but then the chaos broke out I
didn't expect 15,000 people she has to
say this to everyone I never heard
anyone say a message reiterate a point
so constantly as 15,000 people showed up
it's as if she would get paid every time
she said her or something I never seen
anyone say anything so liberally 15,000
baht 15,000 15,000 be with that 15,000
15,000 15,000 15,000 15,000 15,000
people are 15,000 15,000 people 15,000
people 15,000 people 15,000 people
15,000 people all 15,000 of us mafia but
15,000 people showed up to my event can
you guys believe what a big success it
was cuz so many people showed up well
well well as it turns out that wasn't
really what happened we had now a
statement from the city of Garden Grove
police department saying that they sold
4,000 tickets Tana Khan had sold
approximately 4,000 tickets at the time
of the event and the hotel ballrooms
where the event was scheduled could hold
a maximum of 1,150 people so 1,000
people got in and and three or four
thousand people were outside in the Sun
and people were already speculating that
this was the point I think there was
5,000 people there I think they sold
5,000 tickets I think a thousand people
were inside the building and
I think the other 4,000 people were
waiting outside and they couldn't get in
because there wasn't room and it's
pretty clear that that was the case
[Applause]
[Music]
but how did we get to this mess and who
is truly responsible well to understand
Tana Khan we must go deeper I understand
no one cares trust me there is a juicy
stuff in here that you want to know
about but I will already reveal if you
smash that like button right now and hit
the bell button and let me know if you
will be attending Tana con 2018 I sure I
know I will if you look at the invite
for tannic on it literally says in all
caps bold font F VidCon F the current
CEO F everyone who created VidCon and if
you want to know why Tana Khan became a
thing that's why the whole point of Tana
Khan was just point finger at VidCon so
you're already setting off in the wrong
motive Tana wanted Tana con to be at the
same time as VidCon so who'd rival
VidCon but if you really cared about
just doing an event you would have been
more responsible and done and at the
right time when it made sense at the
right venue for the right amount of
people and the more I find out about
Tanic on the more annoyed I get I sort
of gave her a pass in my last video but
she should be banned from holding any
event in the future she should go to
jail because this whole event was just
selling lies it's an actual con and not
the con you know what I mean VidCon is
bad so you should come to Tana con I
said this company is parading themselves
as you know meet your fate and meet your
favorite creators you're not gonna meet
the creator you're not you're not 200
people are gonna reserve a
meet-and-greet than refreshing the page
and the rest of you were gonna wander
around because yep so at VidCon you're
just gonna have to wander around
unlike Tanika where you will have a
great time meeting all your creators
that's the premise of Tanic on you
VidCon so now that all that is being
said you think Greg antic what's wrong
with her Jesus Christ so there was
supposed to be free tickets but also
tickets that you could buy for
sixty-five or seventy one dollars I
don't know
and if you bought the tickets you would
get to skip the lines you would get this
cool goodie bag which would be four
times worth the ticket 276 dollars
that's what she said
was going to be the price of the
contents of the skinny bag well as we
know now there was no separate line if
you had paid there was really no
difference at all if you had paid for a
ticket or not and a lot of people saying
there were no free ticket people there
everyone just had the stat the VIP pass
but it would be worth it because you
could pay $65 for some stickers but the
other lie that annoyed me even more is
the fact that other people were gonna be
at the event there was gonna be Shane
Dawson at the event Shane doesn't really
do VidCon or any other type of
meet-and-greet and right now he's very
popular so obviously a lot of people are
gonna want to show off to Tanic on not
necessarily for Tanna but to means
chained us and this message was pointed
out by a lot of different people the
ones that we have publicly confirmed
right now are along the lines of there's
so many seriously but um me bella thorne
she's doing it is amazing we have Shane
Dawson
obviously as you guys know I am so
insanely blessed to have confirmed Shane
not only Shane but Andrew Ryland and
Morgan like that's to have Shane and his
friends supporting my convention is
literally the most jaw-dropping here
jerking okay we get it
Shane didn't show up because they
wouldn't have been safe for him to do so
it didn't even cross my mind that this
would be something that I would go to
Shane Dawson who I made a song about
said that he was going to support her
his friend Tana I was like oh that's
really cool you know like Shane Dawson
doesn't really go out to convention so
this is like he hasn't gone out since
the first VidCon and then the idea kind
of just kept festering it so
you meet all these creators and your
money will be four times worth that's
the message but okay fine you know let's
say let's still be nice here and say
fine but there were ten a comb was
supposed to be two days so they cancel
the first day maybe they'll make up for
it for the second day that's what I
thought at least in my first video it's
clear now and that they're not going to
do that they're not doing any more days
they just cancelled everything
I like how she says I'm gonna find the
guy in charge she literally spoke to him
three seconds before not realizing that
was him that's right that's the guy in
charge the guy riding around on a Segway
looking like he's 12 years old you go to
goodtime the company that issued this
event that did this event you click on
Michael Wiese - it's Michael Wiese the
CEO oh my gosh that's him
Wow I am a detective
so let's say you sell 5,000 tickets for
$65 $325,000 a venue like an Hotel to be
very generous would probably cost 50,000
a book but let's say 70,000 just to be
extra we're still left with two hundred
and fifty five thousand dollars okay
well let's say you know what get a
hundred thousand to organize this thing
no effing way it costs that much there's
still a hundred and fifty thousand and
you have it run by this young kid
obviously they're just gonna take the
money and run they're not gonna do
another day they're just gonna cancel it
and now ah Tana has to defend herself
against all of this saying everything
would have been fine
unless fifteen thousand people showed up
everything would have gone fine the
entire first time today was incredible
we had a [ __ ] wedding and panels and
Q&A meets everything was seeing a fully
functioning convention with a fully
functioning convention which is why
people literally had to go to the
hospital
[Music]
while she looked like she had a great
time at Anakin hooray and also who
doesn't want to watch a wedding by a
bunch of strangers but you know safety
is the most important bit and
coordination is also a priority of
safety and coordination a giant priority
for tonight I like crushed checks and
between like the barricade the barricade
is the word I'm looking for so I'm
getting like squished up against that
VidCon holds what 20 dock 20 thousand
people are VidCon right now and 15,000
people came over you know
fifteen thousand people guys tano's are
claiming there was two lines that's
right
deal that paid and lines for people that
came in for free right there were line
for everything today there was a I there
were lines for everything uh I feel like
I can I can nitpick so many things in so
many lies but I think will annoy me the
most it's just a gloating you know this
this event it's gonna be the best yeah
everything happens for a reason the
response when the tickets went live in
the first two minutes mm we're gone free
tickets just thousands and thousands a
free thousands of people just want a
free ticket to see me I'm ten among I'm
important no you're not at this point
you know I would suggest you should do a
free event for real and do it right and
make sure that you do retribution give
justice to these people that came you
know spent money to travel convince
their parents to pay for this event to
go there for hotels all these things
just don't just don't do anything golf
and that's all I had to say about tannic
on thank you very much for watching and
leave a like if you enjoyed listening
and I will see you guys in tomorrow's
video goodbye that was a cool outro
maybe I'll stick with that one
[Music]
I'm passed to make the Edgar